for more on all the developments in
washington and beyond we're joined by
gabe d benedetti national correspondent
for new york magazine he's in
charlottesville
virginia gabe good morning to you let's
talk about the week ahead here actually
the next
nine days ahead um assuming that
impeachment sales for the house what's
the schedule
on when that might happen and more
importantly what is the support from
senate republicans
for a potential conviction yeah you're
asking all the right questions here
we don't actually know what the exact
schedule would be house democrats led by
nancy pelosi have said that of course
the first thing that they want to see is
president trump stepping down
or vice president pence invoking the
25th amendment and trying to remove him
from office
that seems unlikely so failing that it
looks like house democrats are going to
try and vote on impeachment
this week this upcoming week and then
what would likely happen is then it gets
kicked
to the senate but as we just heard mitch
mcconnell has essentially said there's
no real way for us to get this done
probably until the 19th at the earliest
so it's possible that a senate trial
wouldn't happen until president-elect
biden actually takes over
you can of course impeach someone who's
no longer in office senate republicans
largely have tried not to talk about
this too much
there are some however looking at lisa
murkowski from alaska
and some others who have said you know
essentially it's time for trump to go
so whether they would actually support
an impeachment is an
open question and one that we're
probably going to hear more about in the
coming days
but if you have that she's not the only
one who of course has been outwardly
disgusted with president trump in the
last few days
so you might have someone like mitt
romney susan collins and potentially
others who have essentially said
enough is enough barring any formal
any of this that you just mentioned are
there other consequences that could come
out of this if none of this happens
well it's a good question i think that
what you're having is a lot of public
outcry about the president
in terms of legal consequences it's an
open question of course
what his exposure is at this point but
you do have lots of people within the
white house
heading for the exits now we've already
had two cabinet members resign
potentially more on the way
and lots of folks who work in the white
house and more broadly in the republican
party are saying
well we had our four years here let's
move on it's time to move on now
you talk about moving on what about the
republican party this has become the
party of trump
how does it go forward at this point
well it's trying to figure that out
right now and there are pretty big
schisms you have someone like lisa
murkowski who i mentioned earlier who is
now
openly questioning her own future within
the party but at the same time just this
week the republican national committee
itself
met in florida and reelected unanimously
ronald mcdaniel
who is the head of the republican party
and a top ally of the president and you
also had a majority of house republicans
actually after the riots vote to object
to the certification of the electoral
college so those folks are still
standing with president trump
it's going to be a massive crisis in the
party that's going to play out for quite
some time
yeah so much to discuss gabe thank you
for the insight we appreciate it